foreign
[Music]
welcome to today's session on how to
extend your Cloud run containers
capabilities using sidecars
I am Sagar randhive I am a product
manager on Google Cloud working on
serverless
and I'm Clayton Coleman long-term
kubernetes contributor and I uh the team
lead for workloads on GK and I work with
Cloud run to make sure we have a
consistent platform for all of your
containerized workloads
before we dive into the topic of
sidecars let's talk a little bit about
what is cloud run
so Cloud run is Google Cloud's fully
managed platform for running your
containerized applications in a fully
serverless manner
Cloud run allows you to deploy and scale
applications fast and securely in a
fully managed environment
it's simple and automated
you just need to bring your container
and we do the do the rest including
scaling down to zero
there is no infrastructure to manage
which means there is no compute cluster
management required or network
connectivity management required
and it allows you to go faster
a developer is able to deploy a cloud
run application in a matter of seconds
so what are the use cases of cloud run
hosting public websites apis where users
can render server-side pages
rest or graphql apis
bi-directional streaming with websockets
or hosting private Services internal
only services that can talk over private
network with each other
which may include websites apis or HTTP
or grpc based microservices
and lastly running data processing
Pipelines
which include processing queues messages
for example Pub sub messages
processing data for event driven
architecture
scheduled scripts as well as background
and batch data processing
so there are two types of cloud run
resources
services and jobs
a cloud run service follows purely a
request driven scaling
instances within a revision are scaled
behind Google managed load balancer
it provides out of the box URLs and TLS
termination
the built-in traffic splitting and
gradual rollouts let you reliably create
new revisions
and
manage you lets you manage your
revisions without any disruptions to
slos
a cloud run service has multiple trigger
points the trigger sources like HTTP 2
grpc events and sockets
and a Cloud9 service provides multiple
pricing options like pay as you go
pricing paper request pricing or paying
for the lifetime of an instance
then you have Cloud run jobs
Cloud run jobs are nothing but a set of
containers that run to completion
they are not triggered by any HTTP
requests
Cloud run jobs
are executed manually or on an automated
schedule
and you only pay while the cloud run job
is being executed you do not pay outside
the cloud run job execution time
Cloud run is available today in all 38
regions and 115 zones
including over 200 plus countries and
territories
today I am excited to announce that
cloudrun supports sidecars
so what are Cloud run sidecars
previously every instance in a cloud run
service ran only one container
we are introducing Cloud run sidecars
allowing you to start independent
containers that can run alongside your
main serving container
you can use sidecars to monitor your
applications in real time
run client connection proxies to connect
to Cloud SQL or alloy DB databases
securing your application networking by
running proxies like Envoy or nginx
alongside your serving container and
much more
and to dive deeper into these use cases
I'll pass over to Clayton
over to Euclid
thanks and there's a number of features
um in sidecar containers that we think
are important so first it's not just one
sidecar it's up to 10.
um we think that sharing in memory
volumes between multiple containers
allows sidecars and their primary
application to work together for more
efficiency generally configuring
kubernetes style health checks for
individual containers so that the
containers can independently fail and
then be restarted specifying the startup
ordering of containers if some
containers have dependencies on another
and we'll talk about that in a minute
and finally if you're starting up in a
certain order you often need to have a
consistent order when shutting down
so
sidecars in general
um you're complementing the main
container with a supporting workload
that adds AIDS in ensuring consistency
sometimes that may be between different
teams between different programming
languages or Frameworks where you want
to ensure a consistent Behavior across
them and sometimes it's a more complex
use case that just wouldn't be possible
if all of the code was in a single
application many of these will be
familiar to kubernetes users in the
audience which already allows multiple
containers to run side by side as part
of the same application while developing
Cloud runside cars we looked at existing
container production use cases
for in addition to taking direct
feedback from serverless container users
this breath really gave us the
confidence that we could simplify and
streamline these scenarios which is part
of the promise of cloud run as well as
add some new features which we'll talk
about how those might come to kubernetes
in the future
a classic uh sidecar use case is adding
a second container to observe the first
you might deploy an open Telemetry
sidecar to write metrics to the managed
service for Prometheus and get the same
metric across all of your runtimes in
Cloud monitoring it might also act as a
temporary relay to help you migrate from
one monitoring service to another for
instance if you decided to switch from
managing your own Prometheus to using
managed service for Prometheus some
users might also use a monitoring
sidecar to perform local analysis of
logs that could look for unusual
behavior in the first container without
necessarily shipping every line to log
service which might save you cost or
increase the performance of the
container itself the sidecar allows a
clean separation between the application
code and a common or temporary problem
managed potentially by the same team or
by another team
adapting existing workloads to run in
Cloud run was a second use case that we
think about
a lot of existing workloads grew up in a
period where they had significant
significant existing proxy
infrastructure to support the
application that might have been in the
early days that would have been Apache
which dates me when I say that but these
days it might be nginx or even Envoy
where you're performing a significant
amount of logic before the request
actually hits your custom application
uh you might also have a need for a
capability that's typically provided by
one of these proxies like uh local HTTP
caching for expensive requests
in this case a sidecar acting as a front
proxy would allow you to integrate those
existing proxies and then potentially
provide a more complex Logic on the way
as requests pass through to your main
application and that could be permanent
or that could be template temporary and
either way the sidecar is letting you
complement an existing app with
functionality that in this case proxies
already do and it doesn't require you to
duplicate that in a particular
programming language so if you wanted to
have consistent cache Behavior across
three or four different microservice
languages because your teams are
relatively diverse you can ensure that
through the Sidecar
going even further into networking use
cases a more advanced use case that
we're starting to see is the use of a
microservice as a proxy for other
services and in this scenario
the envoy proxy can handle incoming
requests
and we've got a supporting application
alongside and that supporting
application actually is doing analysis
or processing traffic as a filter or as
a detecting proxy and then after a
determination is made by the main
application whether this request is
malicious or not it passes that on to a
remote service and I mentioned Envoy
Envoy has a lot of advanced networking
capabilities the pattern could also be
used to bring your own service mesh to
Cloud run or to use this as a serverless
gateway to bridge between
a set of applications outside of
kubernetes and some on kubernetes
a lot of the cases before I've been
talking about incoming traffic another
sidecar use case that we think is a big
opportunity to really accelerate while
still keeping the serverless properties
of cloud run is to simplify connectivity
to the dependencies of our application
here we're using a database client proxy
to authenticate and Pool connections in
a sidecar and that reduces load on our
backend database
the application also can be oblivious to
where the database actually lives as a
nice benefit your local test environment
can use a local connection to a local
database for testing when you deploy
into production for cloud run the same
connection string is in place so you
don't have to change config between the
two environments which is a nice little
benefit it's an opportunity to enforce
secure connections from your front ends
to your databases and to use more
advanced features like I am based
authentication we currently offer open
source proxies for cloud SQL and alloy
DB that you can configure to your needs
as a sidecar
and this use case is also an example of
where startup and shutdown ordering
becomes important
we don't want our main application to
start before the proxy has
because if it does we might have to add
a significant retry logic that might add
error messages to the logs it might add
failures to the events by adding startup
and shutdown ordering you can eliminate
a source of operational friction that
you're using this proxy that gives you
accelerated performance without the main
application having to be aware of it
which is one of the key goals of
sidecars
and finally uh I've most of these
examples have involved a single sidecar
container we wanted to cover one that
had two this is a more advanced usage
pattern and it's similar to some of the
previous ones so in this case you might
have Envoy acting as a front proxy
before requests hit the application but
instead of the application being the one
that's providing that filtering logic we
want to standardize how policy and
access checks are handled across a large
set of microservices and so here we're
showing an example of using an open
policy agent
sidecar which will make policy-based
decisions on behalf of the application
these two sidecars working together get
the best of envoy the best of open
policy agent and providing a standard
way to represent request policy and the
application itself remains agnostic and
this you can think about this as
separating the responsibility between
teams as well the application team might
want to specify the policies for
themselves using the open policy agent
language and the team that might provide
this consistent Behavior wants to ensure
that all the applications perform well
that if they find a bug in the
integration between the two they can
roll that out to all of their
microservices at the same time and so
sidecars also help bring teams together
and uh we stopped we've added two
sidecars here since we support up to ten
there's no reason you have to stop here
you can imagine uh if you so choose uh
combining some of the previous patterns
uh you might have a container to forward
metrics two to apply policy to requests
and a fourth is a client proxy as a
database I'm not saying that's a good
idea but it's something that we support
and as I mentioned earlier many of these
patterns are in common use in kubernetes
and we increasingly hear from customers
using Cloud run and gke together Cloud
run sidecars expands the set of
workloads that can run on both Cloud run
and gke and you can see from the example
configuration how Cloud run requires
only uh only superficial changes to
adapt this multi-container kubernetes
deployment to a serverless cloud run
service with sidecars we often talk
about how Cloud run simplifies
kubernetes sidecars are also an example
hopefully the first of many where Cloud
run helped influence the community key
feedback from cloud run use cases and
customers about sidecar helped us guide
and accelerate a kubernetes enhancement
proposal for sidecars that resolve the
number of long-standing pain points with
kubernetes sidecars and this sort of
collaboration is part of our open
commitment to open standard or our
commitment to Open Standards in the
ecosystem and interoperability between
Cloud run and gke I'll now hand it back
to Cigar to cover some a customer
success story with Cloud run
thank you Clayton those are a lot of use
cases for one feature
let's talk about a customer success
story
NASDAQ is a Google Cloud customer
who is committed to helping its
customers efficiently Monitor and report
on their sustainability performance
in 2022 NASDAQ acquired material a
platform that allows companies to report
on their environmental social and
governance performance
this platform collects measures and
analyzes corporate sustainability data
in real time and generates investor
grade reports designed to be shared
strategically and cost effectively with
stakeholders such as ESG raters
rankers Frameworks and regulators
Metro follows a four-step approach to
report on ESG performance
first it centralizes the qualitative and
quantitative data this data can come
from various sources
including water consumption waste
disposal HR and electricity consumption
then create customized kpis to measure
this data
followed by generating investor grade
reports designed to be shared
strategically and cost effectively which
stakeholders
and finally publish that content online
for interact in an interactive way for
consumption
recently material migrated to Google
cloud from another cloud service
provider let us see why
Metro migrated to Google cloud from
previous stack
that ran Ruby on Rails on a VM
on a different Cloud vendor
the old architecture was hard to scale
because everything was collocated on the
same machine
they were looking for a reliable new
cloud provider that would allow scaling
in the long run
they also suffered outages which
motivated migration to Google Cloud for
its Global coverage scalability security
and high availability
Metro chose Cloud run
Google's serverless compute platform to
fully power its sustainability reporting
software
Cloud run allows material to run
stateless containers that automatically
scale Up and Down based on demand
this means that material only pays for
the resources that they consume when
they are serving requests and do not
have to worry about Auto scaling
policies or managing infrastructure
as a team material wanted to operate
with a focus on developer productivity
to avoid the burden of managing
operations whenever possible
Cloud run is fully managed
so it removes the burden of patching
kubernetes versions and operating system
versions
allowing customer to focus on delivering
value more rapidly to their customers
it's ease of use and deployment speed
also enabled material to create new
products as they migrated from their old
infrastructure provider to Cloud run
a few of materials team members have a
kubernetes background
and expressed interest in being able to
leverage kubernetes features on cloud
run without having to manage nodes or
clusters
Metro has a startup mentality with
ambitious deadlines and product visions
they really enjoy focusing on
development rather than managing
kubernetes resources
Cloud run made the ramp up extremely
easy and made the customer feel secure
knowing that if Cloud run isn't a fit
for a workload they can easily shift to
gke and still have the services
interpretable
before cloud cloud run material would
release codes few times a month
now they can release multiple times a
day making it a lot easier to spin up
sandbox and demo instances for fast
product iteration
so what is materials vision
materials vision for cloud
transformation was to separate databases
from compute so that the storage
performance and capacity can be scaled
independently from compute
this database segregation also helps
them achieve a sock 2 certification
material leverages Cloud run as a
compute layer
and mongodb for legacy data while also
leveraging Cloud SQL and alloy DB for
new services
Metro uses six Cloud run Services per
customer and have over 800 Cloud run
Services running in production today
materials data ingestion tools Powers
over 120 businesses helping them keep
their data clean and auditable
with an edit history and activity log
they allow a wide range of data on
boarding options including templates
scripts and apis
this data can come from various sources
including water consumption waste
disposal HR and electric electricity
consumption
as the application grew
the need to support download and upload
of large files became the biggest
blocker for materials largest customers
customers wanted the ability to upload
large data files without refactoring
their client or server code
now I'll pass over to Clayton to explain
how they accomplished this using Cloud
run and the sidecars feature
thank you
so uh serverless platforms often have to
impose limits on the size of requests to
guarantee a high level of service this
comes obviously with a trade-off is that
you can scale faster and that responses
are short-lived and often can quickly be
resolved
in this case Cloud runs
generous but not infinite 32 megabyte
limit for the size of a request body
created a choice for Metro and how they
were adapting their upload application
for serverless should they update the
serverless code or should they update
the server code sorry to accept HTTP 2
connections which have no limit on the
size of request body at the cost of
additional development time and effort
fortunately
for this talk as well as for Metro the
addition of multiple container support
in Cloud run opened up a simpler path
Metro was able to use Envoy as a front
proxy in the way of their existing
server code to accept HTTP 2 connections
convert the large HTTP two requests into
a large HD P1 request that happened
locally inside of their Cloud run
instance and was then passed over the
local network to the application so
there was no performance hit other than
the latency involved in taking that bits
and the ability to leverage Envoy to do
this versus putting this in their
application code was also meant that
they were able to take a pretty common
scenario that Envoy is tuned extremely
well to so this is another example of
taking
code that already works for a specific
use case such as
handling Network requests and they were
able to quickly integrate that into
their Cloud run instance once the
sidecar support was delivered
by deploying Envoy as a sidecar
container they were able to avoid code
refactoring and update the service but
they were also able to simplify the
management of their microservices and
that use of envoy was really key for
them because their Journey started with
modernizing this application but it
didn't end there with over 800 Cloud run
Services they increasingly anticipate as
we say for the long run the ability to
tie these applications together bringing
Envoy in in the near term as a front
proxy also opened the door to allow them
to bring their own service mesh and to
Define their own rules for connecting
the front end and their uh their initial
upload applications on the database to
more complex micro service scenarios
that they anticipated having in the
future and overall they saw improved
deployment speeds a simplification of
the management of the microservices and
greater scalability
thank you Clayton
so what holds for future of nasdaq's use
of cloud run
in future material intends to leverage
sidecars to secure communication between
GK workloads and Cloud run adhering to
strict compliance compliance standards
of financial services
material also plans to use open
Telemetry collector sidecar to
instrument their Cloud run applications
for custom Telemetry for performance
analysis troubleshooting and capacity
planning
use of open Telemetry will allow sending
the tracing data to Cloud Trace directly
without any hops in between thus
optimally implementing the SLO and SLI
support
Metro's adoption of cloud run for its
sustainability reporting software has
resulted in numerous benefits including
improved deployment speed
simplified management of microservices
and greater scalability
the use of cloud run has enabled them to
focus on delivering value to customers
rather than managing infrastructure
reducing the time it takes to create new
products
with its innovative roadmap Cloud run
has become a game changer
for customers like material to meet
their goals thank you
foreign